there's a Ukrainian counter-offensive
continues to gain momentum and retake
territory in the northeast of the
country Moscow now says that referendums
to join Russia will be held by a
separatist administrations in the
luhanska and Donetsk regions
last night the Civic chambers of the
Donetsk and luhansk people's republics
appeal to the heads of these territories
in order to immediately hold referendums
on joining the Russian Federation given
the current situation there simply can't
be any other solution and referendums
will definitely take place the
leaderships of the DPR and LPR are
already taking the necessary steps to
join forces
local officials from both her son and
Zuppa regia regions have also announced
they'll pursue referendums let's go live
to Gabrielle Elizondo and Keith
Gabrielle what more can you tell us
about these potential referendums
well it came as a surprise that's number
one and it appears to be hastily
announced if you will these referendums
apparently will run from September 23rd
to September 27th so the voting would
start three days from now on Friday this
was announced by local Russia imposed
officials and all four of these regions
and it's important to also point out
that we are still awaiting official
confirmation from the Kremlin and from
Vladimir Putin himself ultimately he is
the decider on these uh sort of things
and we expect to hear potentially from
Putin confirming this uh within the next
few hours maybe even tomorrow but it
does appear that this is the uh being
pushed by Moscow and that these
referendums will go forward but it's
certainly very interesting because
in donesque for example and zapparesia
two of the two of the regions where this
vote is apparently going to happen
Russia doesn't even control those entire
areas yet they only control about 50
percent of each so a lot of people here
in Kiev are viewing this uh kind of
rolling their eyes if you will it's
viewed here as a desperate move perhaps
by Russia and the foreign minister of
Ukraine actually sent out a tweet
responding to this he said in his words
sham referendums by Russia will not
change anything Russia has been and
Remains the aggressor illegally
occupying parts of Ukrainian land and we
will keep liberating that land no matter
what Russia has to say so clearly we'll
be watching this closely because uh
clearly if these votes go forward it is
the first step in potential annexation
of these Ukrainian lands to Russia no
matter what happens this certainly
potentially could change the trajectory
of this war it certainly could are these
uh referendums even legal
foreign
well Russia says they are Russia claims
that what they are doing is just
allowing people to decide for themselves
if they want to be part of Russia or not
and they say they're just protecting uh
uh people that are persecuted in these
areas they claim uh because of their
Russian language speakers that's
Russia's side but the International
Community uh will almost
unanimously say that this is not legal
holding a a referendum that would lead
to annexation in the current conditions
right now do not conform to uh under uh
to
universally accepted rules of
international law for two reasons number
one is because it's being held uh these
are our friend is being held under Force
by Russia by Russian military there and
number two because of that the people
voting can't vote freely and fairly and
there's no International impartial
observers either given all that uh most
uh International lawyers that study this
will say absolutely there's very little
legal basis to make this conform with
international law
Gabrielle Elizondo for us live in Kiev
thank you very much